hey guys this is uh I'm doing a
livestream from my car right now because
uh it's raining and I'm waiting for my
dog to get done at the groomers so I
thought what else am I gonna do I could
do email I don't want to do that that's
not very fun I can go on Twitter I've
already been on Twitter for the last
hour nothing's happening except tweets
that I don't want to read about things
that I don't want to see um so I thought
I'm gonna do a little test here and
livestream from my phone on YouTube I've
never done this on youtube live before
so this is the thing like I can see your
tweets right here tweets oh my god I can
see your comments right here um
Pat says you're so dreamy mr. green hair
says hey the gaming kid says hi Mia says
sitting in cars that's exactly what I'm
doing I just wanted the title to be
completely appropriate because I also
feel so bad about this
I usually don't feel bad about like oh
gosh my windshield wipers are gone crazy
about clickbait titles but I really
didn't even mean to clickbait my
previous video talking about for days
with my Mac that was just I was editing
and that's the last thing that I talked
about is like yeah that's appropriate
the people are searching for looking
specifically for just information about
the MacBook so I don't usually ever feel
bad but that's the only reason that I
did feel bad because a lot of people
were searching for that information so I
think I'm going to do like five days
with my MacBook just to make up for it
and it'll be specifically about the
MacBook nothing else no vlog
yeah I don't know but uh Bree says I
love you from Australia do I like the
rain no I don't but I kinda do because
we definitely need it here in Los
Angeles very very badly but the nice
part about when it is raining is it
clears out the air everything is nice
and it's fantastic uh let's see can I do
a galaxy Mir cake no if you want to see
one of those ro did one on her channel
you can go watch it because she's just
so incredibly talented when it comes to
making things that there's no
competition um Jasmine says it's so cold
I'm sure it's pretty cold where you guys
are if you're not in LA although it's
chilly here right now - my day is good
sitting in your car for security I
should lock my door I think my doors
locked
it's already locked soon as you get in
your car lock your doors guys that's
what my sister tells me and my mom all
the time
Ian says hi it's really cold in the UK
what do I think about Casey ending daily
vlogs
honestly it props in - you know quit
doing something that is super successful
in working for him when you're not
creatively fulfilled that's just a
killer and especially for people who are
creative and love creating content for
the sake of creating content not just
for views
that's incredible um and I think that's
something that I also I think struggle
with is I love making videos but that's
why I've never said that I will do a
daily vlog or I'll post a video every
day because if there's a day that I
don't want to do it and I don't feel
creative and I didn't do anything and I
don't have a video that's good enough I
do not want to have the pressure of
making a video so for me that's super
difficult but I am Todd is asking what
are we discussing today we're discussing
whatever you guys want to discuss Maddie
is in he's at the groomers right now so
you guys are gonna see him here very
soon I can even like leave my camera
just streaming live when I go pick him
up and then I put him in the car would
you guys like that is that something you
guys might like I might not be able to
do that because they're gonna give me a
call when my dog is ready so it'll
probably end the livestream so if this
does happen to end and I don't say
goodbye
bye what's this - oh looky we've got
filters we've got a dream filter oh so
dreamy we've got a glamour filter Wow I
feel fabulous here's a beam eight
millimeter
don't worry some toys are these actually
changing for you guys or is this just
like hey this is how I'm gonna vlog from
now on
oh look at this this is this is I've
never done drugs before but I feel like
if I did this is what drugs would look
like out of my eyes
do you think
I wonder how lag this is is this lagged
does it matter if you guys like the
video
I feel like I'm 750 years old right now
asking the silliest of questions let's
see how many likes we can get so right
now we're at nine ninety one that's not
very many now we've got 1k oh yeah now
we're talking we're really getting crazy
up in here my dog he is um a year and a
half have a year and a half a year and a
half about ish I got him in his
birthdays a note in June I got him in
August so you guys can do the math I'm
not even sure um oh my gosh holy crap
how do we get to 2,000 likes in like
fives holy well my my my head just if I
could like turn my head all the way
around and like continue it like that
like that's what I would have done
because I took my eyes off of the like
for like three seconds and then it's
just like whoa whoa whoa ah ps4 Xbox
Cicely this is what I'm gonna tell you
if you're trying to decide on a console
of what you want to get you need to talk
to your friends what do your friends
have because the best part about getting
consoles is playing with your friends so
if your friends don't have the console
that you have you guys can't play
together so that
but what I will say is I absolutely love
how Xbox has their Xbox play anywhere
although they need to support more games
because right now I think there's I
think Forza and gears and then some like
older games to be able to play
cross-platform is awesome
so um NES am I going to VidCon I don't
want to go to VidCon I think I mean I'm
assuming I probably will go this year I
didn't go last year cuz I was traveling
and you know VidCon I think has turned
into something that it's not something I
mean it's something that I 100% love and
support but I think for creators it's
extremely hard to get to see you guys
and to talk to you because everything is
so quick and fast and you don't actually
get to have conversations with people so
I don't know I think I might just do
like a separate tour on my own but I
probably will go to VidCon actually yeah
I'm sure I will I'm gonna have a dream
I'm dreaming a VidCon right now we'll
see we'll see um
hey dog hurry up I can't wait to see him
he's gonna look so handsome
so he started smelling like trash I took
him to the beach yesterday cuz I was
filming something for a video and he ate
so much sand like he started licking the
ground like he was anyone I do it cuz
people Photoshop me into vulgar things
but let's just say he was licking sand
and non stop looking sand he doesn't
have a poopy butt because I cleaned it I
put him in Jenna's tub you know I just
scraped the crap off of his butt so
that's where we're currently at umm I'm
not the AMAs I did actually really want
to go to the AMAs that I'm so glad I
didn't because it's raining and that
would have been miserable I also didn't
wanna have to wear a dress or dress up
or put makeup on or do my hair so that
is another reason I'm not the AMAs car
tour well this is Maddie this is his car
seat back here do you have any lights oh
those are not
okay well that's alright you know what
um maybe I can put this down put this
back let's give you some light it's
freakin dark out because
because it's raining this is a nice um
rain filled sunroof this is the dog's
bed is his seat belt he likes it now
that's it it's cool oh this is my
steering wheel it's over here have you
guys hooked on to a little car mount
it's one of the CD Mountain ones you're
just gonna like shove it into your CD
Drive I'm surprised I even have a CD
drive do you guys like this sideways
like this does it look good is it a nice
angle should I use the glamour filter is
this glamorous gee oh hey and I wonder
if I can play a song
let me see if I can do that and not lose
my stream because I'm gonna do really
sad if I do okay let's see
what's the song glamorous is it by
Fergie I'm thinking it's Fergie the
steering wheels on the wrong side well
in the US that's like we've got can I
play music to lose you
oh gosh oh goodness oops sorry
goodness we're back we're back guess we
can't play song any of the mobile device
I need another device Janna just a text
piano what should I talk about can't
talk about the filters someone said what
is this lag Make a Porno
oh yes good idea idiot sorry I have
caught this thing it's called dignity at
integrity
such a shame such a shame oh here we go
hi uh-huh there we go
it's good we apply I'm only 11 ho can
you just keep my shout out hi did you
ever convince your sister she was a dog
what they did not
I made my dog he's inside eating his
haircut that's why I'm sitting in my car
for those of you who made just joining
us right now we're also just enjoying
this weather it's great raining in Los
Angeles
one for my dog to get his haircut oh
he's gonna look so so cute they still
played Pokemon go I don't still play it
but I will play it whenever they launch
thing new like Mon give us some new poke
a I'll thank you isn't that I look
pretty today
um that's cool I did take a shower today
I did sort of my hair it's still wet
from what our boring bye I'm sitting in
my car what do you want me to do you're
my freakin like it just like a freaking
cake or do you know like I don't know
the title clearly says behind you Britt
good BRE is currently married which is
kind of crazy to think about um I feel
like the I don't know about you guys
there so that for me is over here so
it's actually kind of it's going it's
fairly not bad to read what do I do this
oh oops
oops I flipped it around there's all
kinds of options I'm just going to start
pushing buttons a snapshot spectacles
pretty cool to be completely honest with
you I thought they're going to be dumb I
thought they were gonna be cheaply made
but the case is very very nice the
charging cable is the nice braided
material and the glasses themselves are
like nice to like okay if you buy like a
nice pair of sunglasses on average I
would say I mean not like a higher end
like anything crazy but like an average
like Ray Bans Orson's like that is like
maybe like 140 170 I would say in
between there so basically buying a
higher-end pair glasses that also have
PEC built into them connect to your
freaking Sun shot they have basically
made me into a snapchat a little bit
more so if you guys want snapchat you
cannot follow I just do
oh no I almost opened up me sunroof
there's no Sun there is no Sun oh
they're closed you up
show you light I don't what's the smell
that looks awful what's this do
oh that's the backlight can you record
I'm
you you Jenna none of my favorite chips
thank you
what noise was there noise it could be
because my cars on there noise what's
wrong oh god noise what is noise if I
unplug this
static
you